from rare strains of kryptonite to the
martian manhunter imaginary friend to a
Gotham City franchise opening up a new
branch here are the Supergirl Easter
eggs that were definitely put there for
the diehards since its debut in 2015
Supergirl has found an audience by
focusing on a more accessible version of
the DC Universe that's easy for casual
viewers to get a handle on after all
everybody knows Superman right here's
his cousin she's got the same powers
does the same stuff is a similarly good
and charming person let's go have
adventures
preferably involving ice cream yes
with that in mind it might be surprising
to learn that one of the show's most
deep cut references comes from one of
the very first things we learn about the
show it's setting it's easy to think
that Kara Danvers is adopted hometown of
National City has a standard-issue
generic name like most of the other
fictional towns in the DC Universe after
all Gotham is just an old nickname for
New York and metropolis is literally
just a word that means big city unlike
those however National City doesn't have
its roots in comics it was created for
the show and its name has a meaning that
goes a little deeper than just being a
city within a nation which many if not
most cities are instead national city is
a reference to supergirls publisher no
not cat grant but DC Comics the fact
that DC stands for Detective Comics is
pretty well known meaning that yes DC
Comics is actually Detective Comics
comics but fewer people know that this
wasn't actually the company's official
name until the late 70s before that they
were national periodical publications
it's a nice nod to the characters
history since national was still the
company's name when Supergirl was
introduced in 1959 but it's pretty
obscure if only there was some major
city that could have used it some
connection to the letters d
ii-in shelter from the storm the 18th
episode of supergirls third season cara
alex ma nell and rain all take a trip to
Lex Luthor's mansion as you might expect
his interior decorating tastes mostly
leaned towards death traps meant to kill
Superman but it's not all wall mounted
machine guns and chunks of Kryptonite
once the big brawl starts up downstairs
we get a pretty good look at his art
collection when Supergirl and rain start
knocking each other through paintings
fortunately Lex kept one important piece
of art upstairs out of harm's way
Saint Michel vanquishing Satan by
Raphael in real life it's a priceless
work of art that hangs in the Louvre and
considering that it's literally a
painting of good triumphing over evil it
seems like an odd choice for Lex Luthor
there is however a reason for it to be
there and it has nothing to do with
Lex's taste in art at least not on the
show instead it's a callback to Batman
vs Superman dawn of Justice where Lex
has a version of the same scene hanging
in his office it is however a different
piece of art the movie used a more
dramatic version by Gustave doré a
called the fall of the rebel angels
which Lex hangs upside down to depict
Satan descending from the sky in a
pretty unsubtle metaphor about his
feelings for Superman
still it's a depiction of the same scene
turns out Lex's tastes are pretty
consistent no matter what universe he's
in most people are familiar with
kryptonite and most comic book fans are
aware that the familiar green K is only
one of several types that have shown up
in comics through the years Supergirl
has tapped into this long tradition to
digging up blue red and even synthetic
kryptonite all of which had their
origins in the comics in the finale of
season 2 however the show busts out a
pretty obscure one silver kryptonite
which first appeared in 1963 Superman's
pal Jimmy Olsen number 70 well except
that it didn't because it wasn't
actually real well even less real than
all the other stuff in the secret of the
silver kryptonite Jimmy tricked Superman
into being worried about a strange new
strain with unknown
thanks only for it to turn out as a hoax
it was silver for Superman Silver
Anniversary the story was meant to mark
25 years since the Man of Steel debut in
1938 the version we see on Supergirl
however is very real or at least as real
as regular Green kryptonite and can
cause paranoia and hallucinations in
Kara's case that means that her cousin
Clark attacks her because he thinks
she's General Zod but this version has a
precedent too it's actually a reference
to the CW's previous long-running super
show Smallville where it showed up in
season 5 with a similar effect on that
shows version of Clark Kent you'd expect
Supergirl they have plenty of references
to the old Richard Donner and
Christopher Reeve Superman movies that
made audiences believe a man could fly
what you might not have expected was
that they'd built huge plot points
around elements lifted from the
Supergirl movie that spun off of them
which at the same time convinced
audiences to stay at home instead of
going to see it Cara's 1984 cinematic
outing is often forgotten by fans
despite the fact that star Helen Slater
made a fantastic super girl in her own
right and would wind up playing Kara's
adopted mom on a TV show the movie was
honestly not very good the inconsistent
confusing plot was largely built around
a Kryptonian MacGuffin called the
omegahedron which had the vague power to
do well whatever the plot required
really chasing it down is what led
Supergirl to earth and the bad guys
mainly wanted to use it for evil magic
spells which you know sure whatever cut
to 35 years later and the show brings in
the omegahedron as a major plot device
in its first season not only was it used
by nan to rebuild indigo making her an
even more formidable threat it was also
the power source for myriad the
mind-control device that Supergirl faced
off against in the last two episodes of
the first season like the movie the show
kept the limits of the omegahedron
civility is pretty vague but they did
identify it as a Kryptonian power source
explaining why myriad was so powerful
that it could even affect Superman
supergirl is obviously chock-full of
ideas and elements pulled from the
Superman comics and with Lynda Carter
appearing as president Marsden there are
far more than a few nods to Wonder Woman
- as far as the rest of the DC Universe
goes however him might be surprised to
learn that show's most prominent fool
from Gotham City has very little to do
with the Dark Knight instead it comes
from the pages of hitman created by
Garth Ennis and John McCrae Tommy
Monahan originally appeared as part of
the 1993 bloodlines event in which every
DC comic of the time introduced a brand
new hero or villain to the universe if
you're wondering why you've never heard
of say shadow strike razor sharp or
ballistic it's because Tommy a
working-class hitman for hire whose
powers gave him a headache when he tried
to use them was the only one who was any
good for some reason gunfire the man who
could turn anything into a gun didn't
click with audiences what does this have
to do with Supergirl
well Tommy was from a neighborhood in
Gotham City called the cauldron where
his main hangout was a bar called
Noonan's if you're a fan of Supergirl
you might recognize that as the name of
the restaurant where cara worked as a
waitress before being hired by cat Grint
the show's brightly lit family-friendly
dining establishment is a far cry from a
dive bar frequented by hired killers
with a literal demon named Bader as a
bartender but when it comes to naming
places on a superhero show there's no
such thing as coincidence incidentally
this one actually has a reference within
a reference one of the most memorable
scenes set and super girl's version of
noonan's comes from the season 1 episode
falling when Kara is exposed to red
kryptonite and briefly becomes a jerk
she flicks peanuts at a shelf of bottles
behind the bar
shattering them if you're a super
cinephile you'll recognize that as a
direct recreation of a scene from
Superman 3 one of the great things about
a show like Supergirl is that with so
much time to work with over the course
of several seasons and so much history
for one of the best characters in comics
the creators can really
back into the past and reintroduce
forgotten elements of a character
take for instance Rick Malvern Malvern
why does it sound so familiar because he
grew up in Midvale even on the show he's
not the most prominent character only
one appearance outside of a flashback in
season two's Alex there he's depicted as
a childhood friend of Kara's who learned
her secret back in their school days but
kept it to himself until he was an adult
using that knowledge to kidnap Alex and
manipulate Supergirl into breaking his
father out of prison unless you've read
a bunch of Supergirl comics from 50
years ago he might have missed that Rick
is actually from the comics although
he's a very different character there on
the page
dick Malvern who got a name change for
obvious reasons was super girls version
of Lois Lane or Lana Lang who was the
childhood friend who suspected super
girls secret identity and kept trying to
get her to review it which in dicks case
once escalated into literally faking his
own death like his TV counterpart it was
later revealed that dick had always
known super girl's identity for a fact
and his elaborate plans were his way of
dunking on the girl he had a crush on
truly a character who lives up to his
name there are plenty of references to
comics to be found in dialogue
throughout Supergirl but on the off
chance that you haven't noticed there's
also a reference in most of the episode
titles throughout the series in season
two we got one that was a nesting doll
of deep cut comics references Supergirl
lives there was once a movie and
development with the same title and yes
it's that Superman movie the one that
Tim Burton was going to make with
Nicolas Cage and a glorious mullet wig
in that amazingly weird batman and robin
style muscle suit all things considered
it's probably a good thing that movie
never happened there's another layer to
that reference though
Supergirl lives was directed by
podcaster filmmaker and occasional comic
book writer Kevin Smith who wrote the
screenplay for Superman lives and has
frequently spoken about the experience
there are even a couple of references to
his unproduced screenplay in the episode
if you're sharp and nerdy enough to
catch them
it's thanagarian snare beast
it won't blow anybody's minds to learn
that most of the characters we see on
Supergirl
especially the ones who run around in
costumes are from the comics guardian
he's from the comics although he's never
been Jimmy Olsen under the mask indigo
the evil robot she's from the comics too
the Martian Manhunter that dudes been a
member of the Justice League since 1961
you know he's from the comics here's one
that might actually surprise you though
remember Zook the imaginary friend that
John mentions having when he was kid
back on Mars what was his name sook
yeah that is also from the comics no
really in the Silver Age there was a
very weird trend of superheroes having
weird little magical imps showing up in
their stories to cause walky troubles
obviously the most famous and the one
that got the whole trend started is
Superman's fifth dimensional foe mr.
mrs. pit lick who appeared on Supergirl
in season two and you've probably heard
of bat-mite that Caped Crusader's
biggest fan those are just the
well-known tips of the interdimensional
iceberg though Aquaman was annoyed by a
sprite named Quisp who had a twin
brother named quake the flash even had
one moppy a guardian angel who was
revealed to have been completely
responsible for Barry Allen getting his
powers in a story that fans hated so
much that it was immediately Rhett
conned out of existence
Zook on the other hand managed to rack
up 18 appearances in the Silver Age as a
full-on sidekick before being shuffled
off into the limbo of things we don't
talk about unless it's on Supergirl
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]